vamos con la actualización de las
noticias económicas con mi compañero
luis méndez de surf y louis después de
otra vez un saludo quisiera que
comenzaremos hablando de tesla que
superó el valor de mercado de un billón
de dólares así es angela es la quinta
empresa que logra dicha capitalización
de mercado en los últimos años en eeuu y
se une a otras como apple amazon
microsoft o alphabet que es la matriz de
google así lo dio a conocer el propio
sello de la compañía y lo muchas través
de un mensaje en la red social 'twitter'
en el que se lee la frase de cual time
pero con un 1 sustituyendo a la letra i
la compañía de autos eléctricos logró
rebasar el hito luego que la empresa de
renta o alquiler de vehículos hertz
anunció que compraría 100 mil unidades a
tesla como parte de su proceso de cambio
a una flota de autos eléctricos meses
después de haber sido salvada de la
bancarrota gracias a la compra de dos
firmas de inversión estadounidenses el
anuncio en evaluaciones por encima de
los mil dólares para cerrar en 1024 con
86 centavos es decir un aumento de 12,6
por ciento respecto al inicio de sesión
pero más notas de empresas la compañía
facebook
e ingresos por el orden de los 29 mil
millones de dólares con ganancias en el
trimestre por el orden de los 9 mil
millones de dólares entre julio y
septiembre todo esto en medio de la
crisis por presuntamente anteponer el
crecimiento a la seguridad bueno lo
hicimos temprano estábamos hablando de
las malas noticias que se avecinan para
el gigante brasileño y es que este lunes
y taboo que es la mayor institución
financiera de carácter privado en ese
país anunció una recesión para la nación
más grande de sudamérica en el próximo
año así lo expresó en su más reciente
informe donde revisa a la baja su
pronóstico de crecimiento para el
próximo año y lo ubica con una
contracción de 0.5 por ciento aún así
mantiene un optimismo respecto a un
crecimiento positivo para el presente
año será de 5% para la institución
financiera las dudas en torno a la
agenda política fiscal del gobierno ya y
es bolsonaro en un contexto de alta
inflación podrían elevar las tasas de
interés y esto generará una actividad
económica más debilitada los datos
presentados con contrasta con las
estimaciones del gobierno que en el
informe de presupuesto que fue
presentado en agosto proyecta un
crecimiento de 2 por ciento vamos a
seguir en américa latina pero ahora le
quiero preguntar por la encuesta de
pulso de sociales qué datos arrojó en
colombia es un instrumento que se
desarrolló el departamento
administrativo nacional de estadística y
entre los resultados más destacados se
aprecia un 39,9 por ciento de los
consultados que son jefes de familia
respondieron que su situación económica
es peor a la del mismo período del año
pasado a pesar de ello la cifra
representa una caída de 19,2 puntos
porcentuales respecto a la medición de
septiembre del 2020 por otro lado la
situación cambia cuando se habla de la
situación del país ya que un 56 7 por
ciento de los consultados expresó que la
situación es peor que hace un año el
estudio se realizó sobre
11.495 jefes de familia en las 23
ciudades más importantes de ese país
bueno y mientras tanto españa nos dio
que va a impulsar los acuerdos de libre
comercio en américa latina y el caribe
como es eso ya lo vamos a ver angela
porque lo dio a conocer la titular del
ministerio industria comercio y turismo
reyes mar o durante su intervención en
el cuarto foro iberoamericano
y mediana empresa sobre ello destacó que
la cantidad de empresas españolas que ha
invertido en américa latina es
considerable ya aplaudió la
modernización del tratado de libre
comercio entre méxico y la unión europea
lo contradictorio es que la noticia se
presenta cuando el gobernador del banco
central de españa pablo hernández de
coss anunció en el congreso una revisión
a la baja a las previsiones de
crecimiento de españa para este año y
otras noticias que vamos a revisar de
nuevo los precios del petróleo que se
mantuvieron elevados de la jornada de
este lunes sobre todo el west texas s
que sirve de referencia para ecuador y
en las operaciones de bolsa esta mañana
logró a superar la barrera de los 85
dólares con 15 centavos previos a una
reducción de 0,2 por ciento para cerrar
en 83 65 este año el petróleo se ha
disparado un 72 por ciento y el mayor
porcentaje ha sido en las últimas
semanas bueno sí recordar por favor los
indicadores cerraron con números
positivos en wall street sobre todo por
este impulso de text light también en
otros indicadores en el mercado de nueva
york por otro lado en europa hubo
cierres mixtos de las jornadas ya
comenzó a operar el mercado japonés con
números positivos mientras que en
américa latina se dieron cierres mixtos
a lo largo del día y por favor de me
gusta con la cifra del día tiene que ver
en este caso con los 5 mil 822 millones
de dólares que es la valoración de marca
de la empresa cervecera corona de
acuerdo al último informe de marcas
realizado en américa latina gracias a
usted ya nuestros televidentes sigan en
france 24
[Música]